ça va se faire vraiment avec une
différence de voix 2000 voient
probablement pour celui ou celle qui
l'emportent
c'est qu'à part encore tous les
résultats des vides ça doit être
effectivement un petit avantage je pense
pour la liste socialiste d'hypothèses ou
besançon les chiffres ne sont pas encore
sortis c'est la règle du jeu je vois que
la triangulaire a fait son effet le
front national
à mon avis ne devrait pas remporter
cette région
on a vu qu au niveau national ils
regrettent même pratiquement avec les
désistements sur eux
franche comté paca également sur sur
alsace lorraine champagne ardenne vous
regrettez que marie-guite dufay arrivée
entre des positions et maintenu sa
candidature
c'est là je crois que je regrette
simplement ce mode de scrutin est
effectivement les effets des
triangulaires sait très bien que il n'ya
jamais de vainqueur en triangulaire
parce que surtout si c'est avec ce type
si peu de voix donc que la région hertz
a même posé un problème d'ailleurs quel
que soit celui qui l'emportent ce soir
vous savez qu'il ya une prime de 25%
mais il y aura pas vraiment de majorité
absolue puisque qu'histoire du bonus ça
est très compliqué